you and your friend steal a necklace
full of a whole bunch of jewels maybe
it's got some sapphires emeralds
diamonds and rubies they're all arranged
on the necklace in some random order
right here I have eight sapphires 10
emeralds Four Diamonds and six rubies
the challenge is for you to make as few
cuts to the necklace as possible so that
you can divvy up the resulting segments
between you and your co-conspirator with
each of you getting half of each Jewel
type for example for the arrangement
that I'm showing here I just did it with
four Cuts if I give the top three
strands to you and these bottom two
strands to your co-conspirator each of
you ends up with four sapphires five
emeralds two diamonds and three rubies
the claim the thing that I want to prove
in this video is that if there are n
different Jewel types it's always
possible to do this Fair division with
only n Cuts or
fewer